We've got a few things already
sketched out on the board,
but let's actually start with the stack that we need to get started with
modernizing with VMware.
Yeah, and IBM Cloud, kind of our basic, or fundamental, VMware software stack is quite simple.
You have your bare metal infrastructure,
where your environment runs on.
So, "bare metal infra".
And then on top, we have your vSphere
and so we actually do automated deployments of 6.5,
6.7, and any future releases from a VMware perspective.
We have NSX, which is the VMware networking tool.
And, sitting on top of that, kind of the brain of the whole operations is vCenter.
And when we look at this,
this is just the very basic fundamental
stack.
There's tons of more components that you can add.
For example, you can add vSan, which is the storage option,
as well as any kind of day-2 operations on top of the stack.
So, for an end user who's coming in and they want to get started,
they could just go directly with vCenter
and IBM will automate and take care of the rest of these components,
get them all installed?
Absolutely, everything we do is from an automation perspective, too.
And we understand that people have different requirements.
I talked about vSAN earlier,
you know if customers prefer other types of storage compared to vSAN,
or they want to use other networking tools,
so they don't actually even need to use NSX, it's just an option,
and what we do from a stack perspective.
I see, OK.
So, we've got a number of things already sketched out here like I mentioned,
and we want to show and really break down how we modernize
from legacy architecture infrastructure to
something like VMware and IBM Cloud.
So, we've got some things sketched out, can you talk through what we have already?
Yeah, absolutely.
So, I think one of the things we were talking about earlier today
was "modernizing" means a lot.
And one specific use-case I want to look at is
modernizing from legacy hardware and legacy software,
and calling out VMware HDX.
So, HDX is a migration, hybridity modernization tool,
whatever acronym you want to put with that.
And so it allows customers to actually migrate from vSphere 5.1,
which can be running on any hardware you want,
and this is an old software stack.
And so, the nice thing that it allows you to do is actually create a connection
where you can actually go from old hardware in 5.1,
into the newest hardware in 6.7
and then whatever VMware is going to be releasing in the future.
And how it does this - it actually makes a kind of a loosely coupled network
which allows you to essentially just stretch your network.
And that's the really cool thing is
they're kind of stretching your L2 network.
It allows you to create these connections where you can bring your own IP,
you can bring your MAC addresses,
and the nice thing, since you're bringing those backwards and forth,
it really provides us true hybridity or multicloud approach.
Right, so, essentially all the connections that the applications may have had previously,
So, IP address, dependencies, and those kinds of things,
you don't really have to worry about refactoring or breaking all those down
since you're bringing your own IP,
since you're kind of having that that model,
those applications continue to work with each other even though now
you know, parts of them are on the cloud.
Absolutely, and one story
from one of our customers that I love to
talk about is you know we had a customer
running on vSphere 5.0, on old hardware,
they were in a datacenter in
California and they were looking to try
VMware on IBM Cloud and they
actually moved that application from
California all the way to Washington D.C.
So you're talking across the country and
so obviously with that they increased
latency compared to the other VMs in
their application, but that application
actually ran better in IBM Cloud you
know even though it was in Washington D.C.
because it's running on a latest
software and hardware version compared
to what the customer was running on-prem.
So, the advantages in the compute
basically outweighed that the
disadvantage of having latency across
the country. Exactly. Wow, okay. And so
that's just kind of one of the use cases
we really like to look at because what
HCX allows you to do it cuts this notion
of hey I'm in a monolithic, or in you
know legacy app, you know hardware
applications, I can't move.
HCX eliminates that by really providing
that backwards compatibility where you
can take everything you have existing
today and move it into your future state.
Right. So, in this kind of example we can
probably say this layer right here, or at
least HCX is enabling that, excuse me,
that translation. So
kind of moving forward, so let's say we
have that that hybrid model on-prem and
on the cloud, what if we wanted to start
moving some of these assets, right. So we
want to move those database pieces and
put them over here, is that is that
something that HCX would help me do? Yeah,
absolutely. So the beautiful thing
about HCX is it allows you to move when
you choose, right. I can group individual
VMs, I can do a live migration, I can do
you know planned migration, and it
ultimately depends on what the customer
is looking for, but really the thing that
we see with HCX and you know any
migration tool it's a lot of it is
analysis paralysis, and with what HCX
allows you to do is it allows people to
feel comfortable because you can start
moving one VM, two VM, and start building
up the comfort of moving you know back
and forth. Right, definitely.
So, you know with HCX I can run this for
you know, let's say however long to make
sure it's stable, we're not having any
downtime that you know critical business
workloads are continuing to run and then
once we've kind of already we can start
duplicating some of these assets, right.
So maybe run some of those DB pieces
over here in the cloud, and I would guess
eventually even think about phasing this
portion out. Absolutely, yeah, and it's all
a matter of what the customer is looking
for but if you think about from a data
consolidation or a data evacuation use
case that's exactly what we see with HCX,
you take what you have existing from an
IP parameter and the nice thing you can
move to the cloud, if it doesn't work you
can move it back, but if it moves it runs
better you can actually shut down your
own data center and save you know a
significant amount of cost, but also get
you to where you want to be, right, cloud,
multicloud environment. Right, exactly.
So, Jordan thank you for breaking this
down for me and our viewers. If you have
any questions, please drop us a line
below. If you want to see more videos
like this in the future, please like and
subscribe. And don't forget you can
always get started in the cloud at no
cost by signing up for a free IBM Cloud
account.